okay so last week cs go fans everywhere
feasted their eyes on an announcement
that
quite frankly they never thought they
would valve has made it so that
vac bans are temporary well
certain ones not all of them but still
it's something
after years of begging and pleading the
iron curtain
has been lifted with valve finally
showing some
modicum of mercy when it comes to
rehabilitating cheaters
and what's even cooler to think about is
what this could spell for the future
of counter-strike
alright you all know the drill like the
video slap
the subscribe button and turn on
notifications so that
hopefully when kenny finally makes his
way onto a roster
you get to watch the video that i make
about it straight after it goes live
dearly beloved cs go fans we are
gathered here today because last
thursday valve published a stunning
unexpected and altogether
earth-shattering blog post
in which they decreed that certain vac
bans
would no longer be permanent but first
things first
what is vac and why are the bands that
it engenders
feared across the whole of esports
remember guys
league players watch these videos too
vac which stands for valve anti-cheat is
the official anti-cheat of valve
published multiplayer titles
such as dota 2 team fortress 2 and cs go
thanks dmitry it's automated which means
it triggers without human intervention
it's also egregiously awful like
only catches the free cheats awful most
spin modding silvers square up against
vac on the regular
and don't even break a sweat don't
believe me
just ask that [ __ ] who openly bragged
about his cheats in a video with
sparkles last august
i don't wake up in the morning wondering
if i've been banned
even after a really cheeky couple games
because
at this point i i just can't see how i'm
gonna get banned also
fun fact apparently that kid's account
did get banned
like days after the interview went live
i guess that's what happens when you
publicly thumb your nose at the cs go
devs
here's the thing though for years it has
been the case that if you have any hope
of playing counter-strike
competitively and you were at any point
in your life
associated with a vac banned account and
it was deserved
not a bug you were in for a [ __ ]
world of hurt see the thing about vac
bans wasn't just that they were
permanent
it's that if deemed legit they were
literally impossible to reverse
if at any point your name had been
associated with a vac banned account
that's it you were done prohibited from
participating in
any valve sponsored events i.e the
majors
for life even if the infraction had been
committed
before your time as a professional
player let's say for instance that you
are a 13 year old
[ __ ] who installs aim hacks to troll
people in matchmaking
let's also say that that 13 year old
blossoms into a world world-class
competitor
who's desperately trying to crack into
the upper echelon of competitive
counter-strike the thing is
they can't because according to valve
they are
were and always will be a cheater
now that's essentially what happened to
brazilian prodigy
vsm whose story we covered back in
december
remember if they all of a sudden make an
exception for vsm
that would open up the floodgates for
all of the other cheaters they've
blacklisted over the years
if vsm walks free why not yampy why not
brax or the rest of the eye by power
guys
where does valve draw the line don't get
me wrong i am all for sending cheaters
to the [ __ ]
shadow realm but to destroy a guy's
career before it even gets started
because of some smooth brain [ __ ] he did
when he was a pre-teen
that's just silly an even crazier thing
happened to finnish phenom yampi whose
story we covered last
april after eating a vac ban back in
2015
on an account that he claims he wasn't
even playing on
yampi was banned from participating in
any and all
valve sponsored events he even went so
far as to sue the developer over damages
that he claimed he incurred
whilst being unable to play in the
majors and ultimately
that's the problem with being a
professional cs go competitor and
having one of these vac bans hanging
over your head
nobody wants to sign you remember if you
can't compete in valve events then your
roster will either have to field a sixth
player
just for the majors which can screw up
your qualification points
or just forfeit playing them entirely
and if you do that then you're also
forfeiting the prestige of competing in
such an event
and the profit that comes with sticker
revenue thus for literally the entirety
of cs go's lifespan
a vac ban has stood as the equivalent of
a death sentence a surefire way to
either end your career
or turn it into a non-starter that is
until last week when out of nowhere
valve made this announcement
in valve's own words a vac ban will only
disqualify a player from an event if it
was either received less than five years
prior
or if it was received at any time after
their first participation in a valve
sponsored event
eg after participating in a qualifier
for an rmr event
so what does this mean well the first
part is pretty self-explanatory
if your vac ban is more than five years
old it will no longer prohibit you from
competing in valve sponsored events
simple the exception of course is if you
received your vac ban at
any point after participating in a valve
sponsored event
that's what the second part says in
other words if you have ever competed in
anything that is even remotely related
to cs go's regional major rankings
and you're caught cheating you're for
life
the most infamous example of this is
probably cali
a tier one french professional who ate a
vac ban
whilst playing for titan just one week
before dreamhack winter 2014.
now to be fair that does seem fairly
justified
if you are a top tier professional
competing on the biggest stage
in the world and you're caught cheating
you probably don't deserve a second
chance
it's not like you were some 13 year old
kid cheating in matchmaking who can
claim that they didn't know any better
then again community members have been
clamoring for years that valve makes
some effort at rehabilitating the i buy
power crew
and they too were salaried professionals
look
it may not feel to you as if match
fixing is on par with using aim hacks
but it's still cheating oh and by the
way if you were wondering what this
announcement might mean for the i buy
power boys
the answer is nothing valve made sure to
note that there are other reasons a
player may not be eligible to
participate in valve sponsored events
these remain unchanged so who does this
help
well it sure as [ __ ] helps vsm who
tweeted out a screenshot of him
uninstalling valorant the same day this
announcement went live
it also isn't terrible for yampi who
after months of litigating with valve to
no avail
made the decision to step down from ends
to join the ranks of team liquid's
valorante roster
of course now that he's been unbanned
everyone in the cs community is
pestering him as to whether he'll ever
consider switching back
i know everyone's asking will i come
back to csun
i can't not just i'm not gonna even
think about it at least in a week
you know we have a long qualifiers i
want to
win the qualifiers and everything and
ultimately that's what makes this
announcement as exciting as it is
the possibilities it opens up finally
after years of begging and pleading with
valve to be more
attentive adaptive and sympathetic to
csgo's competitive community
the developer has shown that it is
capable of
showing mercy as for why valve all of a
sudden decided to do this now
let's be honest it probably has
something to do with valorant
and the fact that we are losing players
left and right that said the start of
kovid marked global offensive's
biggest year to date and for as much as
people love to meme on it for being a
dead game it's actually more popular now
than it's ever been
and as psyched as i am to see vsm
finally make his way onto a real roster
and to potentially get yampi back it's
what this announcement spells for the
future
that excites me the most this could
affect literally countless
young aspiring competitors who we've yet
to even hear of
kids who were either stupid enough to
cheat or
like yampy had their name attached to an
account that was
somehow later plagued with cheats in
either case they won't need to be as
fearful for their future and can take
comfort in the fact that
as it turns out valve is actually
capable of being reasoned with
just please for the love of god don't
think that it's okay
to just suddenly start cheating just
because you're 13.
oh look man we've all been there we've
all been there i was playing retakes
last week and there was a kid
who was literally cheating in the
community server retakes
just like spin body in community servant
retakes like could you imagine
there's no elo on the line like what are
you doing like what why are you here
what are you like are you practicing
your cheats
that's got to be it right
he's practicing his toggling the best
part is that i queued with him later on
in a game
like a separate day on a separate server
and he wasn't cheated so i was just like
this kid was probably practicing his
toggles
it's just so crazy that like i played
with him like a week later
in a different server different day he
was on voice he was on his mic
and i was like oh you're that kid who
cheats and retakes and he got like all
sheepish and i was just like i can't
believe this